can we please talk about this dress give
me give me the rundown how many did you
try and before settling on this one uh
too many dresses I tried on so many
freaking dresses but this is the one
that we chose Valentino it's gorgeous
I think in my opinion um yes he's got so
much bling on right now what's your
favorite accessory this I put it on my
engagement finger because I was like
this is what future husband
no I'm kidding I'm kidding we know but
really know what future husband canary
diamond heyo
this is what I'm talking about this is
where it's at never taking this off and
stealing it I think you should pick it
will now they'll know those three of
your lovely fellow ladies are nominated
tonight Lina
Amelia amazing who are you rooting for
is it a three-way time call make me
choose what kind of question is I was
thinking your sister maybe
I mean amazes my little sister and my
best friends but like Lina has been like
such a mentor to me and Emilia is like
Khaleesi bow down I don't know dude I
can't use all three of them were you
inspired by the amazing Lina to get the
matching tattoo with Maisie what does it
look like I know Lina's will swatch it
out is there I got in Peach because
because my mom wanted it to be as
invisible as possible but now I'm
showing you to everyone she's gonna be
so annoyed what's the significance of it
guys the day that Maisie and I both got
Game of Thrones yeah
yeah very exciting you guys always have
the greatest sisterly dynamic what is
your ideal hangout when it's just you
and her just me and huh we kind of just
buy food from the local shop and sit in
our hotel rooms and watch stupid videos
or what she saw sunny in philadelphia
well stranger things yes you see the kid
no but I want to see Millie Bobby Brown
she like she kills me she's too good for
her age she's here she's here we were
freaking out over her earlier 11:00
alright lastly you gotta make me freak
out right now give me your best tease
that you can about season seven Oh
some crazy dragon stuff happens
the whole thing's amazing and that's
what I can say
you